[Music]
welcome back to CBS Saturday morning
throughout the kova 19 pandemic Dr
Anthony fauci became the face behind the
fight the director of the National
Institute of allergy and infectious
diseases is about to hang up his
government lab coat having served under
seven presidents over his near five
decade career all those years in public
service have earned him some accolades
last weekend he was honored with the
Lifetime Achievement Award at the Ninth
Annual Muhammad Ali humanitarian Awards
did you know him I didn't know Muhammad
Ali but the thing that just struck me is
how courageous he was we met Dr Anthony
fauci in Bethesda Maryland near his
office at the National Institutes of
Health where we asked him what's next
you're not retiring no not even close
what are you gonna do well I don't know
precisely what I'm going to do because I
really can't negotiate a post-government
job while I'm in government my broad
General theme even though I don't know
the venue in which it's going to happen
would be to continue to stay in the
arena of science medicine and public
health that by the book approach he says
has served him well would you be willing
to submit to Congress and the public a
financial disclosure especially with his
critics in Congress I don't understand
why you're asking me that question my
financial disclosure is public knowledge
where would we find it all you have to
do is ask for it
his former boss too not a great doctor
but he's a hell of a promoter
though usually composed he does
occasionally bite back and if anybody is
lying here Senator it is you
did you ever expect science would be so
politicized no there's always a bit of a
politics involved but we are living now
in an era I believe where there is so
much Distortion of reality conspiracy
theory and untruths but you worked for
someone who many claim was really good
at that I never ever
wanted to hurt anybody including
president Trump but when you say that
this drug works when it clearly doesn't
when you say that this is going to go
away tomorrow like magic when you know
as you see the outbreak evolving that
there's no chance it's going to just
disappear
led to the escalation of my becoming the
boogeyman of the far right despite the
backlash why didn't he leave it was
clear that we walked away from telling
the truth in an environment of untruths
then there'll be nobody there telling
the truth and this is Dr kuzmekia
Corbett he has a new boss now thank you
Mr President but he says the damage is
done evidence by the refusal in Congress
earlier this year to provide more covet
funding even as the death toll slows it
continues to rise now above 1 million
Across the Nation when you're dealing
with an outbreak involving the country
and the world you generally think of the
country as your patient and when things
get tough you don't walk away from it
for many fauci was The Trusted figure
above all to guide the ever-shifting
challenges of covet 19. everything else
is noise the adulation though it's kind
of nice haha the hate and the people who
want to kill me is not real it's
unrealistic focus on what you're doing
you just concentrate on what your job is
he has served under seven presidents and
under both parties through many crises
from Ebola all the way back to the one
that started with President Ronald
Reagan the causative retrovirus of AIDS
is the human immunodeficiency virus have
we seen anything like AIDS
before well AIDS brought into people's
Consciousness something that is been
repeated a few times a brand new disease
that you have no prior experience with
and was killing almost everybody that
got infected that was a major major
wake-up call
he was criticized back then too for
moving too slowly as the disease ravaged
the gay community here's the difference
in the contrast and comparison between
then and now and I think people
sometimes misinterpret because back then
the AIDS activists were trying to call
to the attention of the authorities that
we were approaching AIDS like any other
disease in a very highly regulated
deliberative way and if it took you
seven years to develop a drug or who
could or could not get into a clinical
trial so when the AIDS activists decided
they needed to get the attention of
these authorities
they decided the easiest way to do that
was to just attack me the beauty of it
in some respects is that they were
absolutely correct which expedited the
scientific and Regulatory process that
had never been happened before ever in
medicine
and ultimately impacted covid-19 vaccine
development we made major investments in
science for decades prior to covid and
within 11 months have a vaccine that
went through massive clinical trials
that is beyond the UN unprecedented we
will never be able to prevent the
emergence of a new infection what you
can do is prevent that emergence from
becoming a pandemic he's led the NIH
about as long as he's been married to Dr
Christine Grady a world-renowned
bioethicist and nurse he says he
couldn't have done any of it without
she's just solid she was working 18
hours a day by working raising three
children getting a PhD and doing a job
that's an important job no complaints
never complain
never did I hear a crack in your voice
yeah
you'd still get giddy about your life I
do I do yeah that's really sweet it's
the truth after a 54-year career
America's top Doc is in reflection when
you look back on your life what do you
want people to take from it to Remember
You by judging my accomplishments is for
somebody else to do but what I would
like people in a broad sense to know is
that I gave it everything I had and I
didn't leave anything on the field
and something I learned he really is he
still sees patience but he's a a
patient's doctor he believes in
listening to his patients and he had
quite a reputation on the hospital floor
as being the guy you don't mess with his
patients you make sure you do everything
by the book with them he was really
spectacular when it came to talking
about family and how much he owed to his
wife and so it's just it's really
interesting to see the whole the whole
man
um
and you brought it out yeah well he has
quite the smile too but you don't see it
a whole lot of